revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 hoy viernes nos acompaña por
supuesto rosa parés masdéu rosa buena
mañana de viernes ya finalizando una
semana más del programa abrimos esta
revista de prensa con una noticia
indignante y realmente triste que nos
vuelve a llegar desde mexico porque
asesinan al periodista los enríquez
ramírez en el estado de sinaloa no
destaca la jornada 'el universal' o el
san diego y unen trivett entre muchos
otros medios rosa exactamente buenos
días labor antes que todo y es que luis
enrique ramírez era periodista y
fundador del portal fuentes fidedignas y
también colaborador columnista del medio
el debate tenía 59 años y había sido
reconocido y av con multi múltiples
premios y como decías la fiscalía del
estado de sinaloa anunció ayer por la
noche que encontró su cadáver al lado de
una carretera envuelto en plástico de
momento no han trascendido muchos más
detalles pero sí que como decías al
inicio de este programa es el noveno
periodista asesinado en méxico en lo que
va de año en uno de los países más y
grosos para el ejercicio de esta
profesión así es rosa y continuamos el
continente americano pero vamos a eeuu
donde ayer el líder de la unión sindical
de amazon de long island habló ante el
senado para denunciar las prácticas
abusivas de la corporación de besos
contra sus trabajadores los exactamente
y por ejemplo la cadena se en bici lo
que titula es líder sindical arremete
contra las prácticas laborales de amazon
en una audiencia en el senado y es que
crisis es más recordemos a quien ayer
habló ante esta comisión del senado de
eeuu fue el impulsor de la primera unión
sindical de trabajadores de amazon
particularmente en una de las plantas de
staten island en nueva york' y ayer
precisamente testificaba en esta
audiencia del senado que lo que
pretendía era analizar si compañías como
amazon pueden continuar preservando
contratos federales si se llevan
adelante actividades para impedir la
sindicalización de sus trabajadores como
hace la corporación de pesos y
precisamente besos también estaba en
esta audiencia pero decidió no
presentarse por otro lado pues como
decíamos no es más el sindicalista
crítico múltiples prácticas de abusos
laborales contra los trabajadores por
parte de amazon y también insistió en
que son las personas los trabajadores
los que hacen que estas empresas
funcionen y no estamos protegidos y
después de esta audiencia es más junto
con otros sindicalistas fue recibido por
el presidente de eeuu y la
vicepresidenta en la caza blanca y según
anunció en un comunicado la propia casa
blanca
joe biden le agradeció a small si a los
otros sindicalistas que lideren esta
expansión del movimiento sindical en
eeuu los chicos iremos hablando de
derechos laborales en ese país con una
particular portada la revista de moda
vogue en referencia al met gala no rosa
porque pues no todo es lujo y también
hay muchas jornadas a muchas horas
laborales para que todo este megaevento
se llevó a cabo exactamente no no es
sólo todo lo que brilla como se dice nos
estamos viendo aquí la portada
exactamente es una puerta la falsa
insistimos con la que los trabajadores
del grupo condé nast que es el grupo
editorial al que pretén al que pertenece
la revista vogue denuncian a también
explotación laboral por parte de esta
revista y sobre todo en los meses antes
de la celebración de esta gala de la
gala met que está coorganizada por anne
wintour que es precisamente la editora
jefe de la edición estadounidense de
esta conocida revista de moda y
precisamente entre las cosas que
denuncian es pues que les hacen hacer
muchas horas extras no remuneradas antes
precisamente de esta gala y también como
si en la empresa bobby así como otras
reconocidas empresas pretendiera pagar a
sus trabajadores pues con prestigio no e
insiste en el prestigio no paga
alquileres y no paga facturas no hay
aquí pues explicamos un poco la rapidito
esa frase rosa y por ejemplo no me
tocará 2022 en la noche más larga para
los trabajadores alto perfil bajo es
pagos las fuerzas de la industria de la
moda freelancers de productores
asistentes bueno todo esto si cerramos
con lo que ha sido uno de los temas de
la semana la filtración del borrador de
la opinión de la corte suprema sobre la
potencial suspensión del derecho penal
al aborto no borrosa exactamente y si te
parece pues vamos a repasar un poco las
posiciones sobre todo del movimiento
feminista respecto a esta filtración por
un lado vemos a brooke borsoi en new
yorker con esta escena entre dos mujeres
con este temblor en el suelo que una le
dice a la otra tranquila son sólo
generaciones de mujeres y activistas
revolcándose en sus tumbas no con
asumiendo que ningún derecho conquistado
se puede dar por hecho por otro lado
vemos corín en liberación a coco esta
ilustradora que cambia las estrellas de
la bandera estadounidense por perchas no
este símbolo del aborto clandestino que
provoca tantas muertes y mujeres con
hemorragias en relación a precisamente
estos y los abortos no se pueden
prohibir pero lo que se prohibió
finalmente son los abortos seguros y
finalmente ven james en the gardian que
pues muestra aquí distintos
autoproclamados defensores de la
libertad frente la estatua de la
libertad en eeuu que no pueden
que las mujeres pues decidan sobre sus
cuerpos